hi i'm nick gillespie i'm with matt
welch where the co-authors of the
Declaration of Independence how
libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong with America it's out in paperback
at the end of the month we're doing ask
a libertarian 2012 Matt the next
question comes from Morgan Stanton by
email why would any sensible libertarian
support abandoning Afghanistan to the
Taliban and eventually to al-qaeda first
I'm not sensible but second I think the
question is sort of based on a series of
misnomers one is that somehow the United
States is responsible for every
government in the world or at least the
government of Afghanistan simply by
virtue of the fact that we overthrew
their government a long time ago and are
still involved in war there we can't
take responsibility for every single
country in the world that's part of the
reason what we have an unaffordable
government right now we're spending
forty three percent of the world's money
on military spending overall and it also
builds in the assumption that there
isn't any cost associated with trying to
run other countries there's a pretty
good reason to suspect that this is one
of the things that builds resentment
towards American policies and builds
very real life threatening situations
for US soldiers abroad it's not a happy
task to deal with really lousy countries
that are dirt poor Afghanistan in the
1990s under the Tannum Taliban was one
of the worst countries in the modern
history of the world it's not an easy
question but I don't think that
withdrawing troops from a screwed-up
situation that is putting us at risk is
a tantamount to abandoning a country you
know we went into Afghanistan to chase
after bin Laden we lost the trail there
we should have been out of there
time ago Taliban is totally rotten evil
to the core we can help Afghans or other
people push back against that kind of
repression that doesn't mean leaving
troops in there indefinitely and it
doesn't mean pulling out is an
abandonment of American principles we're
here all day ask a libertarian keep
sending us your questions on Facebook
email Twitter YouTube and all the other
tubes see you soon
you